focus in Tasmania is to look at how the
devil might save itself through
evolution and to accelerate that process
our research is showing that the devil
is changing in the ten years since
disease we have seen a really big
reduction in aggressive behavior in
devil's aggressive behavior is
associated with spreading the disease I
think the best scenario just men in
Devil's to be safe from distinction is a
combination of factors and I don't think
there's a one solution or a silver
bullet to avoid extinction and that
combination of factors are devil factors
and Chima factors from the devil
perspective they have to learn or be
selected to be less aggressive too bad
each other less and less often so
they're less likely to pass the disease
and from the tumor perspective also the
tumor has to evolve into a tumor that
allows them the Tasmanian devils to live
long enough to create a next generation
to breed and put a new generation into
the population so I think there's
parallel things happening together that
will decrease the likelihood of
extinction